to Tab 3 and I will mention that there
is a consent calendar
for
sections three four five and six
we can vote them all on one motion
except for the following which have been
removed at the request of some members
under Tab 3
23-180
under tab 5.
23-185
and under tab six
23-200
for those acceptance the rest of the
with this consent calendars the rest is
on the consent calendar Senator gray
moves to it except the consent calendar
who was the second Senator Bradley
further further questions or any any
other ones they want anybody wants
removed seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no consent calendar is adopted
with that ex those following exceptions
first we'll move on tab three
180.
and representative leishman had a
question
foreign
more of a uh thank you very much because
I noticed that there was a savings from
refinancing through the treasury
Department of seven hundred thousand
dollars and I think it's important to
point that out that oftentimes these
kind of gloss over what you've the
positive things that have done with
refinancing but that caught my attention
that's just a thank you oh
thank you very much sure introduce
yourself please my name is Danielle
Shandon I am the Director of Finance for
the Department of Transportation
and she's answered the question
23 180 second motion to accept 23 180 is
there a second
Bradley
Senator Rosenwald all right
further discussion seeing none you ready
for the question all in favor say aye
motion is adopted any any opposed thank
you
moving on to tab five
item number 23 185.
and I guess there's a couple of people
have questions on that
Senator Rosenwald thank you Mr chairman
um my question is really not exactly
related to this item but
um you would you had told us a couple
months ago that Hampstead was out of
compliance with a contract they weren't
Staffing
to require levels so my question is are
they back in compliance and what is this
census
right good afternoon
um for the record Marissa hen associate
commissioner at DHHS and thanks Senator
Rosenwald for the question
um
so Staffing remains a challenge at
Hampstead to the extent that not only
did we issue the letter of compliance
but we now have calls
um once a week with the leadership team
that's there as well as
um at least once a month with the
executive leadership of well path
Recovery Solutions the the clinical
contractor to talk about Staffing in
fact we just had one yesterday where
they briefed me on all of their
Recruitment and Retention strategies I
think what I can say
um so current today there are
approximately 33 youth um uh in the
inpatient census
um and five in our prtf what has been
positive has been the fact that we have
been able to build out the um the array
of services across the Continuum I spoke
this morning with several of you at HHS
oversight about the importance of the
establishment of that prtf but we
continue to hold the contractor
um you know we continue to to closely
supervise their work to to recruit to
retain they're actually completing a
market analysis on salaries to ensure
that what they are offering is
um marketing Market competitive but we
want to see more of those beds open
um currently approximately 50 or 25 beds
could be open if we had more staff so I
think we're seeing the wait list lower
we continue to be committed to getting
um getting it down to zero but in the
meantime it's a tough Staffing
environment
further question thank you quick
follow-up what steps
can the department take to ensure
compliance
so that we get back at least to the
level of kids that were in there when we
bought the place yeah well actually the
level of kids that are at the facility
now is um is pretty close to what it was
when we bought the facility it hasn't we
haven't fallen below that threshold and
in fact we have had weeks where
depending on the Acuity of the milieu we
do rise over 40. so so we have seen
things um certainly stable I would say
but I think it's really about enforcing
the contract about making sure that they
are doing all of the
um quantitative and qualitative analysis
that they're engaging the recruitment
resources not just that they have on
site at the facility but also that this
National company offers
um and really holding them to an
expectation
um as well as pulling in uh all of their
expertise to especially see if they can
lure people uh six miles over the border
to join us from Massachusetts I think
has been another key uh advantage that
they that Hampstead can sometimes offer
so we we're taking it very seriously and
at this same time we don't we want to
make sure that we're maintaining a safe
environment especially for the highly
acute population who is there
we're going back out to bid on the
contract right are we hoping for other
vendors
so the RFP was released
um just about two weeks ago we had a
vendor conference as well as tours and
we look forward to we hope to um to
attract a a variety of proposals and and
well path Recovery Solutions is invited
to submit a proposal as well
um and as anyone will see we we also did
a request for information an RFI to
ensure that stakeholders providers
community members were able to weigh in
on what they feel is most important
whether that is Staffing whether it's
aspects of the system of care whether
it's family orientation and Community
linkages so
um so yes this contract was always
designed as two years so that we could
um enforce it closely provide critical
oversight and then make a decision on
what's best for kids moving forward
further questions senator robertsell
oh Senator Dallas
yeah
thank you for taking my question
um regarding the shortage
sorry
um a prtf a psychiatric residential
treatment facility which is actually
separate from the inpatient hospital but
it is co-located so in essence it is it
does sort of appear as a new Wing even
though it's accredited and operated
separately
so the
um are you having trouble Staffing that
as well is that added into the numbers
that you're having trouble Staffing
um we certainly do have some positions
that we need to fill there but in part
because of the Innovative therapeutic
model that that offers that has
attracted certain staff who want to work
in that environment and we've also had
um we've basically just had an ability
to attract based on people who are more
in the Residential Care world than they
are in in the hospital world so so we're
doing okay there but we definitely have
positions particularly
um some counselor and nursing positions
that we need to fill in order to
increase that census from the current of
about five or six up to a full capacity
of 12. thank you
thank you for for coming when we had
when we had the young people at New
Hampshire hospital we had how many
in Residence there was it about 40. it
was before my time so I'm looking to see
below 40 is what I'm I'm being told they
were moved in uh the move from New
Hampshire hospital to Hampstead was in
uh 2019. it would be moved would we move
to New Hampshire hospital we moved all
of the children to the to hibson
hospital that's correct and what is the
what is the capacity of of hips Head
Hospital yeah so um we believe the
capacity is 70. if you look at the
official licensure it says 110 110 would
never be realistic and I think when
several of you visited we talked about
that um in theory if you filled every
bed and everyone had three roommates I
suppose you could get 110 patients in
there but that's not realistic given um
the evidence-based treatment guidelines
of today so 70 would be the max that we
conceive of right now one unit is closed
because of some Renovations that are
being completed some furniture that's
being moved in I think we pointed that
one out to you on the tour but um but 70
is what we are hoping to get to good for
the question what's our waiting list
today yeah
um the waiting list today is eight youth
I believe
um and um and then on the adult side it
is 17.
so 17 adults they're being taken care of
at New Hampshire hospital
so those are 17 adults with
um ieas with involuntary you know
emergency admission
um paperwork who are awaiting a bed for
placement
who are currently in emergency
departments okay
this would further it reacted to the
court order we have to get them out of
the emergency departments ASAP correct
that's correct yeah and the Departments
as I spoke at the last um fiscal I
believe um we are we're working on that
we're working on the mission zero effort
um so we're fully committed okay okay
thank you thank you very much
representative leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question in the body of the
letter that we're looking at it said
that General funds may be requested if
other funds unavailable do you see the
likelihood of needing a further request
for General funds or right I'm going to
let our CFO Nathan white take that one
good afternoon Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer
um
the original budget for State fiscal
year 23 included the the arpa funds as
well as the the um the revenue that that
um the other funds in the state fiscal
year 2425 budget uh we do have a little
over nine million dollars of General
funds currently budgeted so in in 24 and
25 we do potentially expect to utilize
General funds in addition to our in
addition to our patient revenues we
discussed this during the budget process
with division three members as well as
with Senate finance that right now we
are still building the history of what
that what that Revenue mix looks like so
if you look at New Hampshire hospital
it's closer to 50 50 patient revenues to
General funds right now
um at Hampstead Hospital the patient
revenues are coming in higher than what
we had originally anticipated which I
think is good news
um the the big Wrinkle In This of course
is we are going back out to bid
uh for a contract to be effective next
July 2024 anytime you go back out to bid
you do potentially face increased costs
I don't necessarily know what that will
look like and how that will play out but
from my perspective on the financial
side I do just see that as something
we'll we'll keep an eye on as well as
for the 2627 budget and I know that
sounds like eons away but I'm sure it'll
be here before we know it we are going
to be keeping a close eye on what the
general fund need will look like for the
next biennium and right now it does
appear
right now that that that the mix could
be less General funds than we originally
anticipated for this biennium but we're
going to wait and see how that plays out
right now we don't even yet have a full
year of Revenue because we do have some
delays with the patient Revenue payments
that we do receive but that's something
that we're keeping a close eye on and
we'll provide more information on that
as we go forward
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative Edwards of our question
uh yes sir that's pretty simple for Mr
White I'm sure and that is uh this uh
item 185 is
opening up 150 000 to help pay for wages
that were higher than anticipated and
because we were able to hire people
faster than we thought okay so so that's
I guess that's fine news but what it
makes me curious about is in the next
budget has has this line item been
properly funded so that this is an
exception because of a startup issue or
on an ongoing basis is this budgeted
properly sure so the budget in the state
fiscal year 23 budget we put this
together uh the the former CFO and the
New Hampshire Hospital CFO as well as
collaborate collaboration with the
existing Hampton Outlook staff at the
time they put together that budget the
current budget for 23 and they made
certain assumptions about what we would
hire the six executive team members at
the the six unclassified positions at
the time they were non-classified
and there were assumptions that it would
probably come where the positions would
be hired potentially in the range of
step three or four or five
um in order to compete with the private
sector we did have to make a number of
offers that were higher than that and so
for our budget the next go around those
have been budget accordingly at their
current salaries so I don't foresee an
issue here um we do have some positions
that are not at that Max stepper at that
higher step and if there's turnover and
we hire at a higher rate I mean we
certainly have that potential likelihood
or maybe not potential likelihood but we
have that potential scenario but long
story short uh yes we are all set for
the next budget
yeah
Senator Bradley thank you uh Mr chair
this is really just a thank you to the
department uh for the resolution on the
payment in lieu of taxes letter and a
thank you to Mr Kane
um you guys work together and solved
that little problem so thank you very
much
so representative Edwards thank you
thank you sir Senator Bradley's comment
just just made me realize I had a
question around that and that is
um
are we are I I talked to you on the
phone a week ago and you you gave me a
very nice update on the status of our
payments to Hampstead and and at the
time there was a hang up on being able
to to make the next set of payments to
Hampstead uh I I forget exactly how you
phrased it I wrote it in my head as
there's a paperwork problem is all but
you've got the money in the budget uh
but what what what are we telling
Hampstead these days about when we can
write the their next check sure so uh
just for context for everyone's
awareness so during State fiscal year 23
the department made two payments to the
town of Hampstead for a total with GNC
approval they were unencumbered payment
requests for a total of approximately
177 800 and change and
um in the by during the legislative
process during the Senate phase we
discussed this we discussed the notion
of 178 thousand dollar payment to be
made to the town I've already prepped
that GNC letter ready to go it should be
at the July 19th meeting so once we have
that authorization from GNC we will go
ahead and make that hundred and seventy
eight thousand dollar payment for State
fiscal year 24 and then we look forward
to working with members of the
legislature on on a future solution
there
did you say July 19th
I did am I am I getting that wrong I may
be getting it wrong
oh I'm August 5th it's actually a GNC
item it's it's not a fiscal item we
don't need to worry about it thank you
no sir
is there a motion for the item
some move
all right all right motion
you hear who made it
Senator gray second by Senator Rosenwald
to adopt item 23-185 any further
discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye aye
opposed no the item is adopted
moving on to 23 200.
there's a senator Rosenwald had a
question
I think my question is well I have a
couple questions one
commissioner nice to see you nice to see
you too so all told today you're I think
asking us to approve 12 million dollars
in Arbor funds okay and I'm recalling
that when you came to Senate Finance in
April you said there were no more our
funds available for us to do anything
with so
I'm wondering about that discrepancy so
at that point those the pro the programs
that you're seeing today were already in
the pipeline we just hadn't gotten them
to the point of uh ready to be brought
to fiscal so what you're seeing today
really is at the very end of the actual
items uh that are going to be allocated
under this original amount
um for the uh State fiscal recovery
funds great and I I had questions for
the judicial branch if they're here yes
they're here
the chief justice is here if you have a
question
judicial branch
got some serious help today so welcome
chief justice
good morning Miss uh good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee
hi uh for the record Gordon McDonald
chief justice with me is Judge Ryan
guptal who leads our mental health
Docket in the Circuit Court
thank you so by understanding is that
um
all of our designated receiving
facilities are now again doing video
conference
iea hearings I hope that includes the
new one at Dartmouth Hitchcock but is
that correct uh let judge Gob toll
correct me but all drfs are conducting
video hearings Dartmouth has not
established its drf yet
okay and if I could follow up so the
hospitals
are not doing
video conference iea hearings in the
emergency department but I'm wondering
what happens if someone
needs a sign language interpreter
for their iea hearing is that being done
by telephone or
so how is that being handled that's a
great question Senator Rosemont thank
you for that
um we've actually had several of those
types of hearings and we have been able
to make special arrangements with the
hospitals uh to in those particular
cases it it's a lot of video screens
because you need at least two ASL
interpreters per Hearing in some cases I
think we've had three because we've had
one person on screen and two people in
the facility but we have been able to
arrange video for that no we're not
we're not doing sign language
interpretation over the phone and that's
if I can just add a little bit that's
the the fact that we were able to do
that when the hospitals knew that was
the only way the hearing was going to
happen is one of the reasons we've
reached out again to ask
can we pilot with you to get video on a
more regular basis than we are we have
about four facilities that are in
conversation with us now to potentially
start piloting those in the Ed which is
where we want to go well I I
congratulate the judicial branch for
getting us away from telephones I think
it's
Justice may be blind but in this case we
don't really want it to be thank you
and I would move the item
motion a second to adopt 23 200. motion
by
Senator gray second by rep Senator
Rosenwald
all in favor say aye aye suppose no the
item is adopted thank you for coming
thank you very very much Mr chairman
moving on to tab seven and the regular
calendar
item is 23 182 is there any discussion
on the item
move the item
Senator gray moves to adopt 23-182
Senator Rosenwald seconds is there any
further discussion maybe we have a
little discussion on this I was I was a
little slow
um okay I I Edwards has a question we'll
wait for somebody to come to answer it
thank you Mr sure
um I think I was just a little um
challenge with my reading comprehension
I could could you just verbally explain
what this explanation says it says
good afternoon this is Trish Tilly I am
the director of Public Health
so in general we are working out
um a budgeting issue at the end of the
year
um typically we use two a couple of
sources of funds to pay for overtime
both
um Revenue that comes in from licensing
fees we are restricted in the amount of
Revenue that we can use from licensing
fees and then we supplement that
additionally with General funds so these
um I'm just checking with my friend
Nathan here
um so in here we we do not have enough
although we have budgeted licensee fees
there isn't enough actually in that
account and so we need to move some
general funds in
that is correct
um there is a statute that limits our
ability to collect the licensing fee
Revenue Beyond three hundred thousand
dollars each year in the current
biennium there was an error in the
original budgeted amount it was three
thousand dollars higher than it should
have been what this request does is
we're transferring unused funds from one
account from from the public health
Laboratories account we're moving that
over to this account
and then we're going to be writing down
the revenue that we can't technically
earn within this account in the current
in the in the budget that was just
approved and signed into law this issue
has been rectified so it will no longer
be an issue going forward but this is a
technical correction to address that
issue that was identified
uh yeah thank you Mr Wyatt and Miss
Tilley I these two paragraphs didn't say
that to me and I it's again it was
probably my problem with reading but
thank you for the explanation
any further discussion on the item we've
already have a motion in a second for
the discussion seeing none are you all
ready for the question all in favor say
aye aye aye opposed no that item is
adopted moving on to tab eight
item number 23 186.
there any questions on the item
second
representative Eastman knows the item
excuse me Senator Bradley seconds to
adopt item 23-186 any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye
aye opposed no that item is adopted
moving on to tab nine
item 23 187
second
Senator Bradley moves to adopt the item
Senator gray seconds item 23 187 further
discussion seeing none you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no that item is adopted moving
on to 23 197.
second
Senator Rosenwald moves the item
Senator gray seconds to adopt 23-197
further discussion seeing none you're
ready for the question all in favor say
aye
aye opposed no
that my item is adopted
moving on to tab 10.
I'm sorry did you have a question intent
on this next this next item okay
item 23 199. we're having a natural and
cultural resources we have a question
for whoever's present for that
department
please introduce yourself
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee I'm John devivo general
manager at Franconia Notch State Park
and Canon Mountain ski area
Senator Rosenwald is recognized for
questions thank you Mr chairman I
remember last year there was a line for
the cost for state employees I don't see
it this year and I'm wondering if that
got dropped from the collective
bargaining agreement or
I don't believe so I don't recall
specifically having that line item in
there it may have done so at the request
of the committee typically that would be
part of our winter special use policy
where it's uh it's not really an off
product but it's something that's
non-mainstream that does come before you
annually the winter special use policy
and this year we'll be doing that in the
fall along with the rest of our fee
package
okay thank you thank you
further discussion
second
Senator Blaisdell moves to adopt the 23
199.
did I say something wrong
bird cell please
known her for 20 years
Senator bird cell moves the item
Senator gray seconds it
sorry about that Virginia
further discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye oppose
no that item is adopted
moving on to tab 11.
item 23 188
Department of Corrections any questions
on the item
representative Leachman has a question
for director Hanks
good afternoon for the record Helen
Hanks commissioner of the Department of
Corrections and to my right is Ben
Carbone our pharmacist in charge of the
department
senator leishman for a question
I'll take Senator that's
representative Leachman for a question
once they start to go bad
foreign
good afternoon commissioner so I had a
question on the
page 9 of 10 where there's a listing of
all the transfers from full-time
employees special payments
and you've taken all the money out of
that line throughout the different
sections of your budget what was that
for
representative leech that's a great
question because I asked it myself what
happened was with the teamsters
specifically they bargained a special
overtime premium payment and when that
was forecasted in our budget the amount
we received was over what we anticipated
spending so we did have an opportunity
in this budget to use it for this
purpose and hence why it's before you
today it's an atypical line item for us
okay thank you thank you thank you Mr
chairman very welcome
yeah
Senator Rosenwald thank you
um commissioner have we budgeted enough
in the 24-25 budget to cover this level
of prescription drug spending Senator
Rosenwald that's a wonderful question
I'm concerned we may not have these
increases started occurring uh right at
the end of the budget finalization
process the cost increases that are
referenced in the letter that pharmacist
Carbone has identified uh keep going up
every time I look so I've stopped
looking that's a bad joke with that
stated they have aggressively started
looking at potential contracts with
specific pharmaceutical providers to try
to reduce those costs we're taking very
emergent interventions in addition to
the inflation reduction act that was
signed last August of 2022 that
President Biden and the federal
government has specifically trying to
Target reduction of State United States
pharmaceutical costs they're staying
quite abreast with those opportunities
because as you know we take those costs
very seriously and we're trying to we're
trying to slow that inflationary Trend
as quickly as we're seeing it happen
thank you you're welcome
move the item
second
representative leishman moves since
dalessandro seconds to adopt item 23-188
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say aye opposed no item is adopted
moving on to tab 12.
item 23 189
more of the Department of Corrections
are there any questions
just what would
if I wrote Senator dallasandra thank you
uh commissioner are we having any luck
uh recruiting
uh so that we don't have to uh spend
this overtime buddy and we we actually
uh take the pressure off those who have
to work the overtime over and over and
over again how are we doing in terms of
Recruitment and Retention uh thank you
for that question Senator dalessandro
you'll see in the packet on the very
last page it shows that the average
longevity of our Department's employees
is hovering almost to 10 years and then
on the security specific trending chart
you'll see the large retirement
retirement Spike we saw post covet has
started to normalize itself this year so
those are two good healthy signs in
addition we've been and continue to run
a southern based Recruitment and
Retention committee with a
multi-disciplinary approach and a
northern uh Recruitment and Retention
committee and those are producing more
full-time candidates I want to thank the
legislature for their support and
Shifting the wages and support of the
agency that has made a difference your
vote to continue that ten thousand
dollar incentive will continue to make a
difference to set our department aside
from other law enforcement but as we're
graduating eight new certified law
enforcement Corrections Officers today
we already have 14 in the Q sir and so
that's also a good sign so right now I
have very positive news and we've
started a per diem non-benefit
non-benefited relief opportunity that
we're hoping will also produce new
full-time employees so we've even and I
thank the National Guard recruited and
National Guard service member onto our
team so we're making great strides great
so is that is our vacancy rate still 259
it's shifting I uh in it is not as bad
as the 51 percent so it's headed in the
right direction
so further questions from the committee
members seeing none
second
who made the motion Senator bird cell
move Senator Dallas Andrew seconds to
adopt 23-189 further discussion seeing
Nani ready for the question all in favor
say aye aye opposed no the item is
adopted
tab 13.
Veterans Home
any questions from the committee members
the items correctly
Senator bird cell moves the item Senator
dallasandro seconds to adopt 23 198. for
the discussion seeing none are you ready
for the question all in favor say aye
aye opposed no we have a late item
from the Department of Education dealing
with project Mountain
any questions from the committee members
representative Heath has a question
thank you Mr chair
for the record Frank edelblue
Commissioner of Education
Tammy valencourt CFO for education
thank you Mr commissioner for taking my
question
um this item is calling for seven
million dollars
um to go toward Renovations at crutched
Mountain now I'm fairly familiar with
cartridge Mountain over the years
dealing with it in various different
ways
my understanding was that it went out of
business and I and now it must be back
in business again why are we
um
transferring seven million dollars to
crotchet Mountain your explanation
didn't answer my question very well yeah
no problem so let me just give you a
little bit of background so um the the
facility itself did not ever go out of
business
um working with health and human
services at a certain point they were
prepared to shut down the uh current
operator of that business because they
were not meeting their required
specifications for the operation of that
facility when that operator was notified
of that they announced an intention to
shut down the operation which would have
been disruptive both for our DD
communities as well as our disabled
communities in the student population so
we sought individuals outside of that
Community who may be interested in
operating that facility we did locate an
organization called Seven Hills which is
a Massachusetts entity it happened to
have as its uh president the an
individual who ran Cratchit Mountain
many years ago they agreed to come in
and operate that particular facility and
so they did they stepped in at an
emergency basis as a result of that we
did not have you know as many as 50
students being sent back into
residential settings which would have
been inappropriate for them as they
began to get and so they kind of did
this in an emergency type of a basis
they negotiated with the former owner to
acquire the facilities they so once they
got their hands around the facility they
began to do an assessment of the
infrastructure associated with it and
they discovered some deficiencies and so
my understanding is they they sought
from gopher funding to be able to make
some of those Capital Improvements to be
able to both operate the facility but
really put it at its capacity right now
they're not able to service all of the
needs and so
they're not able to operate at their
their capacity for their licensure
because of some of the deficiencies in
the facility so they sought that funding
from the from gopher through the ARP
funds they were awarded those those
funds are being are going to be
transferred and managed through the
Department of Education I think the the
choice of the Department of Education
was because we have a building aid
process that we can manage this type of
a construction process through so that's
where we will manage it and so that's
really I know I know I'm not answering
your question why did they get seven
million dollars and someone else didn't
other than that was the award that we
got from arpa
is it a pro not profit or for-profit it
is a not-for-profit
and this will go through the department
of Ed why not help in human services so
I think the reason again it could have
probably gone through either one of the
agencies I think the reason why the
Department of Education was selected is
because we already have processes set up
for managing construction projects like
this just in our school building Aid
processes and so we're just going to run
this through as if it were kind of a
school building Aid project all right
thank you
thank you Mr
so
is this going to be just for day
students or is the Department of
Education going to be
setting up
and renovating a licensed residential
care facility so this includes a
combination on so remember it includes
multiple aspects from an education
standpoint we have residential students
so these are students with a disability
that requires them to be in a 24 7
residential setting and we also
accommodate day students at this
facility from the education programming
side they're licensed to for up to 105
students presently they have 22
residential students they have about 15
to 20 day students that are
participating in those programs so they
obviously they're not able to fully
utilize their license and so it includes
a combination now the facility itself
also includes you know developmental
disability population that would be you
know Health and Human Services you know
clients are on that same facility the
work that we're doing is primarily
focused around the the educational
aspects the educational facilities
although clearly the the facility
improvements are going to improve things
like the administration offices required
some infrastructure improvements as well
and that would benefit both of those
programs whether it's an education
program or a Health and Human Services
Program good
um our New Hampshire children going to
be
served in priority versus children from
other states they absolutely are I've
received personal assurances because I
got that question from you all that was
the intent it is a New Hampshire
facility I spoke with the president of
Seven Hills and he gave me his
assurances relative to that process that
the New Hampshire resident students
would be given priority for the slots
that are available both on the
residential programming as well as the
day programming thank you
representative leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
so according to like local press not
that the Press is always correct but
there were articles that ran in the
local paper that covers this area that
said people were laid off the place was
shutting down you said it's really never
shut down is that correct that's correct
and one further question Mr chairman
so that the problem with laid items is
sometimes it doesn't give us a lot of
time to do research so what do you know
about Seven Hills do they operate
similar facilities if they do how many
wear that type of thing yeah
um so when we were in search of some
type of an operator for this facility if
we first approach all of our other New
Hampshire operators that operate similar
facilities to see if they would be
interested and then we basically looked
at where because oftentimes New
Hampshire students are placed in
residential facilities outside of New
Hampshire so my second tier was I went
to the facilities that were outside of
New Hampshire and that's where we first
came up with Seven Hills that's where we
source that and then we I literally just
reached out to all of those places where
we had
um you know students placed and I said
is there an interest in this and then
you know the uh the funnel narrowed
until uh Seven Hills was the the
individual entity who was open to doing
that Seven Hills up operates very
similar facilities in Massachusetts that
already housed today both as residential
or day students New Hampshire students
although I don't know if Massachusetts
has any day students but they have
residential students so they're they're
already in the business in terms of
these types of facilities which provides
us some degree of assurance that they
will be able to you know effectively
manage that facility and I do think you
know an important aspect is the fact
that the the president of Seven Hills
was the CEO of crotchet Mountain you
know like back in the 90s at that point
in time and so I was familiar with
um you know the operation the geography
you know the communities around there
that they're serving and I think that
that was helpful for us as well
thank you thank you Mr chairman
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair uh good seeing you again Mr
commissioner
um so so my questions really kind of
relate to the business assurances that
go along with this money
um it says that there's a 15 million
dollar need for renovation this is seven
million of it uh where is the other 8
million coming from assuming it's coming
from Seven Hills do we have a guarantee
on that and if we spend this money and
we do the renovations do we have any
assurances about uh how long they will
commit to operating if they we spend the
money it's Federal money we go so it's
supposed to be wasted I guess but uh
that's a joke but uh but I just want to
make sure if we invest in renovations
that we have good assurances this is
going to be an ongoing operation yeah so
and again keeping in mind that a lot of
this is kind of deferred maintenance
type of stuff so the assurances that we
have received is relative to the
projects and this is probably why we're
pushing it through our building aid
process that we will this These funds
will be used to do renovation projects
that will be able to be completed and
put in service all right so my concern
was that we would uh you know do half of
a building and say like okay well we got
part of it done but you can't use the
facility because you haven't finished
the work so the the only assurance I can
give you is that
um you know the work that we're doing
we're going to make sure that they
complete the facilities that they are
working on of the 7 million to the point
of them being accessible to New
Hampshire students for service in terms
of the uh the rest of the facilities
um you know my understanding is at Seven
Hills is uh you know they may have a
commitment already or they're in the
process of seeking an external
commitment from you know a financial
institution to be able to complete those
and I have spoken with one Banker about
that already that was connected to me
relative to the financing just to
understand what that project looks like
thank you and then and then what about
any commitments they make to operating
in the future should we go forward with
this project yeah so I mean they're the
only commitment we can have again if
they if they face some type of
insolvency they wouldn't do it but they
have told us that they are committed to
it but we don't have we don't have some
type of a written Assurance from them
and I'm not sure what that would be
worth if they faced an insolvency
circumstance uh we're probably in a
better circumstance to just uh recognize
that this is an institution that's
already in that business and has had
some success in that business uh you're
probably referring to the fact that
crotchet Mountain just in my own tenure
as commissioner has changed hands
several times and uh so we do hope that
this one sticks is a good way of
describing it but I don't know beyond
that if I can provide that Assurance to
you
representative Heath for a question
thank you
um Mr chair I am very uncomfortable with
moving forward with this item I really
think we I think the commission has done
a good job of trying to assure us but
there are so many unanswered questions
um
if the chair would be willing could we
move to table this item
that's a legitimate motion you could
make that motion and see if it passes I
would like to make that motion Mr chair
motion to table is there a second
representative Heath moves to table
Senator Rosenwald seconds
if it's possible for me to comment that
but there's no discussion on that
tabling item so
um
the discussion there should be no
discussion to table it's just a straight
vote we'll do it by show of hands all in
favor of tabling raise your hand
four all opposed
six motion does not carry
is there a further motion
proof question
Senator graemos to prove
Senator Bradley seconds to approve the
item
further discussion I had a question
represent Senator thank you
just a a couple of cookies I'm fairly
familiar with cartridge Moten and a
what's still operating in at crotchet
mode
you know there was a school there was
the brain injury situation there was
some kind of extended care now some of
that has has moved in another Direction
but what's what's left in operating you
said in this in this little presentation
there were 31 buildings on the campus
well how many of those buildings are
still fluctuating
uh and and what what are we actually
doing at crotchet about as we speak yep
so I mean I can speak to that directly
relative to the education program here
today uh they have a license for 105
students they're serving 22 residential
students they're serving
um I believe it's somewhere between 12
and 21. we're not sure if somebody
transposed a number uh day students
um but they're serving day students
every day all summer
um you know failure to move forward with
this would require us to find placement
for these students in New Hampshire we
don't have capacity in our New Hampshire
um you know service providers at this
point in time which would be difficult
uh you know some of those residential
students may end up in you know out of
state in New York or in California
someplace else from a Health and Human
Services standpoint I believe they
continue to provide services there as
well but I'm not completely familiar
with all of the Health and Human
Services operations on that facility but
I do believe they continue to have the
brain injury facility they continue to
provide against you know residential and
other services to developmental
disabilities community
word for the question
when would we uh were planning is
committed with the Senate we were told
that there wasn't any more ability now
all of a sudden there's seven billion
dollars available for this project where
did this seven billion dollars come from
so the the funds were passed to the
Department of Education from gopher
right from the a from that facility so
we don't manage that facility but that
was this grant was provided to us for
the purpose of um you know doing these
renovations
so so the the origin of the foods from
golf it was inappropriated was it re was
it recalculated or was it re was it
reapportioned so again I don't where did
seven million come from all of a sudden
we heard there wasn't any money yeah
seven billion appears so I don't manage
that Grant so I don't know how that
money came into existence I think Taylor
is here and he may be able to respond to
them okay great thank you
um
Taylor Castle commissioner I am here for
gopher so as I had mentioned Senator
Roosevelt earlier this was a project
that we've had in the pipeline now uh
for several months uh working with them
working with the Seven Hills operation
to understand what their needs were
going to be where they where the funds
that they were requesting uh eligible
under arpa what are the expenditure
categories that they would fit under
those sorts of questions we had to go
through a process to uh to move those
funds to the point of getting them to
you here today so it is within the
category that I had mentioned to Senator
Rosenwald that when I spoke really at
the last two meetings about how we were
done with the obligations under or
allocations under under the fiscal
recovery funds
um that's true we still have we still
had a couple of these items left in the
pipeline to bring to you and those are
the ones you're seeing today
thank you Senator Rosenwald for a
question
um
when I look at the website for Seven
Hills it looks like
they deal with clinical
cases and Behavioral Health so
could you please tell us why the grant
is going to the Department of Education
and not to Health and Human Services yes
uh ma'am as you can imagine that was
some subject of discussion I think in
the end as commissioner edelblue
mentioned because these requests are all
infrastructure based and renovation
based not programmatic in nature I think
we felt that uh you know given the
management capabilities at Department of
Education along projects like this that
that was a that was a relevant and
jurisdictional fit for these funds
and toward that end I mean I know it
will go through our building a process
Amy Clark who I believe you've met in
the past so she's an engineer and she's
managing these School building Aid
projects projects already so I think
that you know that was the understanding
that we would manage it like a
construction project at a school
representative Edwards for a question uh
thank you Mr chair
um earlier today in HHS oversight
um it was uh we were reminded that in HB
49 with the sununu center we allocated
in that legislation
21.6 million in arpa money and we said
only arpa money could be spent on the
sununu center and so as I'm looking at
this seven million dollars and I'm
worrying about cost overruns and the
like
um I I really want to see that sununi
Center built the department in testimony
said that they think they've got a good
estimate that they're going to come
under it but I'm just still interested
in your perspective on contingency
reallocation of funding because in terms
of higher priorities I would still put
this in a new center above this project
and I I don't want to I don't want to
short something
right neither do we uh Representatives
so I think as as you know we've been
through the last couple of months now
particularly as it relates to
um uh and I guess it was I think it was
at the May meeting where we extended the
spending deadlines under arpa
expenditures that you've approved
through uh the next fiscal year but only
until June 30th of 2024. the reason for
that is because we have an obligation
deadline at the end of 2024 and December
31st of 2024. so effectively that will
give us an opportunity to see and give
agencies and others uh the next year to
burn through those expenditures at a
rate that are going to be able to get us
to a full expenditure down as close down
to zeros we can get it by that December
30th 24. so having a deadline of a year
from now gives us that opportunity to
get a check in on how that's going now I
don't mean to wait we're waiting for a
year to see how everyone's doing we're
working with all agencies on a very
regular basis and the the dashboard on
our website gives that number updated on
a quarterly basis which correlates with
the federal requirements that we have
for reporting so I guess what I'm saying
is that we have left room at the end of
this to have affirm ideas to how those
funds are going to be spent over the
last six months of the obligation period
a year from now and it'd be at that
point that we'll see you know how what
are the priorities what are we going to
have get done during that time period
um because even if you and I don't mean
to confuse the matter but even if you
get beyond that 2024 deadline we still
have until 2026 to spend everything so
the obligation deadline I'm referring to
is the end of December 2024.
um
what are the questions on on 23 204
representative leishman thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking I hope my
last question you said that based on
your letter on your testimony that is
about 15 million dollars needed to
address a number of things from parking
lots to housing heating water treatment
but there's no guarantee that Seven
Hills is going to come up with that
other eight million dollars is there so
which is why we've tried to structure
the work such that the this money as
it's invested will be in assets so that
they can be put into service
um so they may need to uh you know redo
some other things but that's deferred
maintenance um you know even just
earlier today I was at a university
system of New Hampshire board meeting
and we've got you know a large deferred
maintenance number there as well it
doesn't mean that those
um you know facilities are not
functioning but it's deferred
maintenance and so what we've done is
we've prioritized the things that are
going to benefit the educational
programming thanks thank you Mr chairman
see no further discussion I'm looking
for a motion to approve
23. Bradley
Senator green moves Senator Bradley
seconds to adopt FIS 23204 are you ready
for the question all in favor say aye
aye opposed no
can I see a show of hands all in favor
hold your hand up
six all the posts
four thank you motion is adult
sure thank you very much chairman Weiler
item 23203 consistent with the
provisions in House Bill 2 which allows
the appointing authority of the
legislative branch employees to Grant uh
the pay raise which was granted to the
state employees as well as the
legislative employees this morning of 10
effective July 14 2023 2 effective July
12 2024.
thank you
so good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee I'm Katya Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health and yes we have seen the letter
we were sent a copy at the same time you
were
um and what is stated in that letter is
correct we have been working over the
last several months and this has come
before this committee before this issue
was raised and we have our data
analytics team working with the
association and their data analytics
team and we continue to reconcile the
numbers
um what I believe they've referenced is
the fact that of course they've served
individuals our dashboard shows zeros
for the last several months and that's
because as we've been taking this time
to make sure that we're providing in a
very transparent way the information
about how many are being served I did
receive a prototype of the information
that will be forthcoming in future
dashboards and we'll be sharing that
with you hopefully as as early as your
next meeting which I'm not sure what it
is I think I heard August
how big was the discrepancy in numbers
so I I don't have that in front of me
today
but I think what has been of concern by
the centers and our concern as well it
wasn't reflecting the increase in the
numbers of individuals being served so I
don't have the exact number of what the
discrepancy was but we are showing an
increased trend line knowing of course
that we've added a number of services
but they also have been constrained by
Workforce and we're hoping with the
Medicaid rate increases and other
measures that are being taken that will
be able to support everybody who has a
need
so did I understand you to say you've
taken steps to get this more accurate in
the future
absolutely absolutely one we want to be
able to do that and we want to make sure
that we talk about the limitations of
the data and the data that the centers
have versus what the department has and
we want to be able to present all of
that so that you have a better
understanding of what's happening out in
your communities
thank you for addressing this concern
I guess we are ready to move on to the
audit
oh wait a minute about the dashboard
better Senator Rosenwald for a question
not about this piece
about the dcyf
peace
it's so weird not to see Joe ribs
thank you
um
when I look at
table
four
it shows that in April
the
dcyf for referrals fell by about
two-thirds
and I'm just
wondering
what happened
I mean
that's a giant decrease
good afternoon my name is Marie Noonan
I'm the interim director for dcyf
and so I'm not sure exactly the point in
time that the data was pulled it could
be that it wasn't the full complete
month in April
um it it also could in fact be that
March was a higher number because if you
look at March it was a thousand and then
the 937 is more in line with the other
months so it could just be that in in
the month of March we saw an increase in
call volume and assessments to to the
agency
um well if I look at thank you if I go
back really for about seven or eight
months
it was over two thousand
I see that yes
um could you get back to us absolutely
thank you sure can
further questions for HHS
seeing none now I think we're ready for
the audit
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the records Steve
Smith director of audits for the LBA and
joining me from our office is Christine
Young she's the senior audit manager on
this audit she'll be presenting and also
we have uh commissioner step from Dr Ray
joining us as well so with that I'll
turn it over to Christine
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Christine Young and I will be
presenting the report on our financial
audit of the Department of Revenue
Administration for the fiscal year ended
June 30 2022.
this report is presented in two sections
the first section is the management
letter section prepared by the auditors
and it contains our report on internal
control and compliance along with five
audit observations
the second section the financial section
contains our independent Auditor's
report followed by the department
prepared financial statement and notes
the focus of my presentation will be on
the observations and recommendations
however we'd be happy to answer any
questions that you may have regarding
any part of this report
if you turn to the table of contents
this report includes five internal
control comments none of which are
material weaknesses and none of which
require legislative action
the department concurs fully with the
findings
the discussion of the observations and
recommendations begins on page three
observation number one discusses risk
assessment which is one of the five
recognized components of internal
control
we recommended the department adhere to
the requirements established in their
risk management plan
and formally document and retain meeting
notes and reviews to evidence
performance of risk assessment
procedures
observation number two on page four
reports the Department's monthly
reconciliation of revenues recorded in
its Revenue information management
system to the New Hampshire first state
accounting system was incomplete and
lacked a formal review and approval
we recommended the department review
reconciliations for completeness
Implement a formal review and approval
control procedure and document the
preparer and approvers completion of
their respective roles in the process
observation number three on page six
notes that the department did not
adequately review and approve
significant year-end tax accounts
receivable information
provided to the Department of
administrative services for inclusion in
the state's annual comprehensive
financial report
in addition administrative Services
inadvertently omitted from the state's
annual report some corrections totaling
21.8 million dollars that the department
made to their original submission
the Department's financial statement in
this report includes the corrected
information
we recommended the department Implement
a formal review in approval control
procedure for year-end reporting to
administrative services
and work with administrative services to
develop a more formal reporting process
for communicating information
observation number four on page 8
reports that policies and procedures
supporting Department operations have
not been kept current
we recommended the department review and
revise policies and procedures to reduce
the risk of disruption in operations due
to the departure of key employees
and to implement a monitoring control to
help ensure policies and procedures
remain up to date and reflect current
practices
the last observation is observation
number five on page nine
here we note the department does not
consistently record expenditures in the
correct accounting period
we recommended the department
established controls to improve the
financial reporting process for accounts
payable
and require vendors with significant
contracts to remit invoices timely
especially prior to the state's fiscal
year end
behind the tab is the current status of
audit findings from our 2014 Financial
audit of the department
of the eight findings included in that
report
six findings are currently resolved one
finding related to risk assessment is in
the process of being remediated and one
finding related to accounts payable is
currently unresolved
the financial section of the report
follows with our Auditor's opinion which
was modified as a complete set of
financial statements was not presented
the statement of revenues and
expenditures is on page seven
followed by the notes to the financial
statement
we also included a one-page letter with
the report
this is a required communication to
governance to inform you that a material
adjustment to the accounting records was
proposed and recorded as a result of our
audit
that concludes my presentation I'd like
to thank commissioner stepp and her
staff for their cooperation and
assistance during the audit they were
wonderful to work with
thank you
comments from the agency
thank you Mr chair good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee Lindsey
stepp commissioner at the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue Administration
behind me today is assistant
commissioner Aura Lemire
business administrator Shelly garlano
and Senior financial analyst Lauren
O'Sullivan who worked very hard with the
LBA during this process it was an
enjoyable process for the agency that
typically is the one doing the auditing
we appreciate at times being the uh or
one being the auditor we appreciate
being the Oddity it's interesting to sit
on the other side of the table we thank
the LBA very much for their time effort
and energy during this audit and I'm
happy to answer any questions about any
of the observations
I don't believe most of that staff was
there five years ago when the previous
audit was done is that so that is
correct we've had quite a bit of
turnover
um over the past few years
um so they definitely got their feet wet
as part so you read the previous audit
and knew what to expect right very good
questions from the committee members
Senator gray
um just wanted to get you to comment on
the prior year item number five
and apparently it relates back to the
finding five this year just trying to
give you a chance to comment sure so um
item number five from this year which is
also noted as being unresolved from the
prior audit so
um the and that also relates to the
letter that you have as well with the
five hundred and nineteen thousand
dollar entry that is the result of two
invoices
um one invoice we did Miss putting a
double asterisk on that invoice when we
were paying it in order to bring it into
the prior year that invoice was
immaterial it was around forty thousand
dollars
the second invoice was more significant
that invoice was received from a vendor
past the 60-day period that the
department of administrative Services
allows us to note that it should have
been paid in the prior year so we did
not have the option
um to essentially
note it for the prior year
so we uh there's two things that are
going to happen going forward one we're
going to contact our vendors as the year
is ending to make sure that we receive
the invoices in a timely manner and two
I believe the department of
administrative Services is going to
extend that 60-day window to 90 days so
if that if the window was 90 days then
we would have been able to
reflect that payment appropriately but
unfortunately it was not an option to do
that because the invoice had been
received late
I didn't see the commissioner shaking
his head that he was going to 90 days
but he is now all right thank you
further from committee members
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I want to talk about the way
um on page 12 item five is written up
the first sentence review with the Das
the appropriate accounts payable
policies and procedures that should be
employed to report accounts payable at
the end of the fiscal year
as I read that sentence it suggests that
there's a a training shortfall that
employees are not being trained properly
on uh on the policies and procedures of
accounts payable but then as I listen to
your two examples that sounds like
understandable
mistakes in a very busy system and so so
I'm just curious if that first sentence
is really
reflective of the kind of corrective
procedure
that is appropriate
correct me if I'm
I believe this is an overview of the
findings from our 2014 audit and whether
or not they are resolved so that
language is from 2014.
the issue that happened in this audit is
different as I just explained but
um the LBA has decided that it is
similar enough to this finding this
previous finding that they're they're
treating them essentially the same
oh mayor
okay so what what you said just actually
makes me a little bit more nervous
that that that there's no that this is
still an unresolved issue even though it
came in 2014 and this is as basic as
reviewing the procedures with the people
who are supposed to implement them and
that's just hard to imagine
I guess the
due in 2014 was reviewing the procedures
we have obviously since done that
however during this audit there was the
one forty thousand roughly forty
thousand dollar invoice that was missed
and so it is deemed that it is still not
resolved
okay I I guess I'd want to give you at
least one dot then I appreciate it the
remediation and process I appreciate
that all right all right thank you
further discussion
representative leishman thanks Mr
chairman and seeing that the department
of audits and
forgives interest and penalties I think
they've done a pretty good job so they
don't need any interest in penalties
from us so
Senator Rosenwald thank you is it
correct that Mr Smith is retiring
and if so could we thank him for his
service to this state
yes I am retiring next month so
thank you and uh if I may if I can say a
few public thank yous
uh first I'd like to thank Sherry
Rockburn and Tom Martin
who was the Comptroller back then
or give me the opportunity to join state
ranks and begin my State Career with
administrative Services back in 2001.
I also want to thank all the financial
accounting colleagues around the state
well I had the pleasure of working with
and who assisted and were integral
in the preparation of the 13 annual
comprehensive Furniture reports that I
was involved with during my years at DES
next thanks to Mike Kane for his strong
support these last almost nine years
thank you Mike and to Jeff Patterson
for reaching out and recruiting me to
this position
it uh it's been a privilege to work with
you
to the art division
not only has it been a privilege but a
joy
to work with such a fine group of
talented professionals
past and present
over these last several years
and lastly to the fiscal committee for
your continued support to the audit
division
and the work we do
it's been an honor to come before you
and co-present our work product
thank you very much and best wishes to
you all
and in honor of commissioner susani
Senator Del Sandro I plan to string
together a long series of great great
American days
express our acclimation for these many
years
thank you very much
we will be thank you very much
thank you now we will proceed with this
letter
representative Mooney thank you Mr chair
I move that we accept place on file and
release to the public in the usual
manner the Department of Revenue
Administration financial audit report as
heard today thank you
motion and a second further discussion
seeing none all in favor say aye aye
opposed no that motion is adopted thank
you again Mr Smith wish you well and
your future
all right so the next item would be the
next meeting
yes
Mr Kane and I've decided we don't need
to meet in July
anybody object to that
did I mention I'll be in
English so we might move the August
meeting a little
closer to the uh beginning of the month
than the Third
Friday
so 8 11 is that a problem
August 11th I won't be here I have a
conference
all right you will be absent
it's in the morning
it will be it will be available in the
afternoon but not in the morning
how many other people are affected by
such thing
you have all alternates at uh in the
Senate yes we do
so if we met Friday morning at 10
we'd be missing one but I'm always EX
excited about how faithful all our
alternates are they show up every
meeting so I don't think we'll have a
problem
she had a conflict in the morning as the
afternoon acceptable to the rest of the
it's hard to anticipate but if the
afternoon will work for there's any
problem to the Friday afternoon the 11th
one o'clock will work
all right we'll do it again at one
on August 11th and then from then on for
the rest of the year we will likely meet
on the third Friday
so if that's going to be a problem let
me know otherwise we'll plan for that
from
September through December
thank you very much is there a motion to
adjourn
motion to adjourn and a second all in
favor say aye aye
I suppose no
thank you all for coming that was a we
went through it pretty quickly
appreciate all the work
thank you
thank you Mr Kane thank you all we'll
see you in August
already